colin pitchfork who raped and murdered
two schoolgirls in the 1980s has been
released from prison let's speak to our
crime correspondent martin brunt now and
martin how was he
released well nobody's actually seen him
but we're told officially that uh he's
been freed
and this comes
um six weeks after the final attempt to
try and keep him inside uh had failed
the justice secretary robert buckland
had objected to the parole board's
decision to free him but it was a
half-hearted objection
mr buckland hadn't at the original
parole hearing raised any objections and
it was really a political move after an
outcry particularly from
um pitchforks the families of his two
victims so once that hurdle was overcome
simply the authorities had run out of
legitimate reasons
to keep pitchfork uh in prison he'd done
his time more than his time he'd done
five years beyond his minimum sentence
so he's now a free man um he'll be
working under or living under very tough
restrictions
but to head off any criticism the
ministry of justice has put out a
statement
in which it says this
public safety is our top priority which
is why he is subject to some of the
strictest license conditions ever set
and will remain under supervision for
the rest of his life
if he breaches these conditions he faces
an immediate return to prison now some
of those restrictions there are 36 in
all include limits on his travel his
internet access any work he wants to do
i mean he's only in his early 60s so he
may want to do a job contact with other
people particularly children
will be limited and and he is going to
have to undertake regular um polygraph
lie detector tests um and
those conditions will last for the rest
of his life there's been a brief
reaction from the family of one of his
victims dawn ashworth her mother barbara
has said this was on the books but i
don't think he should be breathing the
same air as us